hi i'm alvin and today i'll be showing
you how to make my barbecue rib sandwich
to feed a crowd
[Music]
so this recipe is pretty cool because
it's basically a giant version of that
favorite fast food rib sandwich that
pretty much everybody knows it requires
a entire slab of baby back ribs which is
kind of awesome because
i love ribs i love
meat so basically the concept is that
you cook barbecue ribs pretty normally
and you just add some seasoning some you
know your glaze your barbecue sauce to
make a nice rack of ribs
so the funny thing is the idea came to
me at a very weird time i was like
in my dorm like senior year of college
and like at like 1 30 a.m i was like
browsing the internet looking for
barbecue videos to fall asleep too i saw
this video where they had taken a giant
slab of barbecue ribs and
they were like oh my god like i think
they flipped it over and then he wanted
to show the camera how
how tender the meat was so he like took
one of the bones out and i was like oh
my god like you just straight up pull
the bone right out of the rib the person
did that to show how tender it was and i
was like whoa but wait
what happens if you take all of them out
so i had this brain blast at like 2 a.m
laying in bed on like a week night and i
was like i want to try this kind of
slowly pull the bone
right out of each sort of rib and the
key here is actually not to just tear it
out you want to keep as much of it as
intact as possible because you want it
to be a nice sandwich but the tricky
thing is you know
if it's super tender it's gonna fall out
that's totally fine um and i gotta say
when i was making this video i
definitely like the moment i first
pulled a bone out it was just so
satisfying and all the right in all the
wrong ways that i just like kept doing
it and i was like man i should probably
record this
i was like pulling out the bones from a
very close-up angle for a very long time
so kind of after that's done
you kind of cook it you glaze it you
know you cook it normally as you would
[Music]
and the trickiest part is transferring
that slab of beautiful glazed meat onto
a nice bun and the key here is to
actually get a nice piece of toasted
bread that matches whatever the ribs
you're going to make so as long as you
get some bread and you toast it and you
butter it and it fits with the rib
[Music]
and you kind of add you know you can add
whatever toppings you want i
i like onions so i chose to add onions
and some parsley
[Music]
the coolest part is when you actually
serve it because when you slice it along
the edges of the sandwich you're
actually going to get one rib per person
and it's because like that's like one
sandwich per person
so you just cut it up into what you
think where the ribs were everybody gets
a nice sandwich that they can just chomp
on and it's you know it's like a
boneless rib and what could be better
than that i was surprised it actually
turned out really well it's kind of like
your childhood uh you know fast food rib
sandwich reimagined with actual ribs
because who knows what's in the original
one
but that's pretty much it and i think
this is a great recipe if you
want to have friends over it's great for
potlucks it's great for parties you know
i think you can pretty much blow
people's minds and if you know you do
make it tag me send it over i i love i
love when uh i think it's awesome when
you guys make our recipes so i think
that's a keeper for sure if you want to
entertain if you just want some ribs or
if you're just looking for lunch like me
on a weekly basis
you